Hello and welcome to HoloTalk, the internet radio broadcast for lasers and holography, enjoyed by listeners throughout the world.
I'm Frank Defratis, and I'll be your host for each installment, bringing you news, guests, and everything holographic.
Now, please enjoy the latest show.
Paul Bearford.
Hi, Paul, how are you?
It's Frank Defrates.
Well, hello there.
How are you?
How are you doing?
Driving back to Connecticut, I hear.
I am indeed.
I thought I'd give you a call and see what we could do about putting the show up and uh having you uh on the show.
Okay.
I have uh one of the shows up already with Michael Anderson, but I can always uh put this one up in addition to that and then send out another email blast to the subscribers.
That sounds good.
So you know everything's uh set up and ready to go, I take it.
I went in uh just to sort of lay the show out.
Um you played the show out this morning and and last evening, and uh they're gonna finish the lighting today.
But um primarily this is uh our our nature of holography show, which is uh it's our nature of holography too.
We have two shows, which we circulate essentially the same content.
One show is bigger than the other.
Uh the show in in uh in reading is a is uh I guess image-wise, probably a little over uh forty five, 50 images.
Wow.
And uh they're packed pretty tightly in that show.
But it's it's a it's a nice little show.
It's uh sort of an introductory to holography, um using images from nature.
And it goes through and and uh talks about uh their panels uh historical uh a timeline which is sort of uh drawn from our website on the history of holography.
And um and then the images are are there to show to sort of show people uh how holography is different than other um media like photography, of course, and and uh and drawings and paintings.
There's there's a nice little section called the natural collection, which which uh has twelve embossed holograms using uh a variety of different embossing techniques.
Uh embossing being what uh you see on of course on the National Geographic or or your MasterCard and Visa cards.
Yeah, yeah.
And uh each one of those images are from nature and they they show how the uh the they show the the exact same object done as a hologram and then as a photograph or as a pen and ink drawing uh or as an embossed uh image.
Yeah, and it's so there are twelve of them and there's twelve different images and each showing uh uh holography uh uh versus another type of of uh uh representation, which is which is nice.
It might be uh uh particularly interesting to uh graphic art students who who are are dealing with such matters.
So uh that's essentially the show.
It's it's uh got uh one of the old time favorites, of course, uh uh uh Kiss Two by Lloyd Cross.
Yeah.
Which which I I just had to add in there.
It's the ol it's the only integral or holographic movie that we have in there.
Okay.
But it's such a classic.
Uh everything else is is uh reflection pieces and and boss pieces, which of course are the transmission bearabacs.
I imagine it must be uh a number of pieces from uh Richmond holographics.
There are because they produced a ton of of those.
So um uh Greg Cherry is in there and uh Edwina Orr and uh but you yeah, Richmond holographics is is definitely in there because they have some great images.
Yeah.
Uh you don't happen to have Lindau Man in there, do you?
Well, I d I have it in the other show.
Oh, okay.
Um and I I was looking around uh to see if I could I could find another copy.
I didn't want to break up the uh the show because the other show goes down to uh museum of of uh uh science and and uh in uh Daytona Beach.
Okay, that's another question I wanted to ask you 'cause there are a number of listeners in uh Florida that I told uh there would be a show down in Florida and they were just uh curious.
Why don't you while while I have you on the phone, I don't want to hold you up because I know you have a long drive.
Why don't you tell the listeners a little bit about the Florida show too?
Well, um let's edit this out because I don't have I don't have my notes in front of it.
All right, any dates or anything?
Months?
Uh Paul Park?
I'm looking for those right now.
That's all right.
Uh the uh Richmond, just just out of curiosity for the holographers who are listening to the show, the Richmond holographic pieces, are they on uh glass plate or film?
Are they the film?
They're all on film.
They're all on film, okay.
Yeah.
We found that to be the uh the the best thing to use because you know traveling this stuff around glass is is break down pretty easily.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna do a presentation during the month, and what I'm going to do is uh I don't know if anyone spoke to you about it, but I'll be taking a few photographs of a few selected holograms and then telling the stories behind the holograms.
Oh, that's nice.
As part of the presentation.
Yeah, I mean there's an interesting um on our website there's a there's a uh uh a handwritten note or or series of pages by Lloyd Cross, which you might want to take a look at.
I I found it fascinating him talking about the early days of of uh uh of the school of San Francisco School of Holography.
Yeah.
Um you know, but the KISS would be a a fascinating uh uh talk about that as well because that it just goes they're you know, it's a classic the classic image.
It's just a great image.
Everybody loves it.
Well it's Super Bowl weekend that it opens on, so if if anybody's a holographer and they like the Super Bowl, what a weekend that would be.
You can go to the holography exhibit on Saturday and watch the Super Bowl on Sunday.
That's right.
And of course they're open for I think this show goes through uh April.
April twenty-ninth, yeah.
Right.
So there's there's uh plenty of time to see it and there's plenty of other things to see at that museum too.
I didn't realize that that's a great museum down in the middle.
Oh, isn't it that's a beautiful museum.
They actually had a holography exhibit there twenty years ago.
I know, I know, and I've forgotten who who produced that.
Yeah, and I the the name that uh uh oh Doug no.
Oh Doug Tyler?
No, he just he wasn't doing it then.
But I'm not sure who actually I believe it w from Saint Mary's College or something like that.
I think it was.
Is it could have been.
That's Doug Tyler, right?
That's right.
I actually wrote the review for that show at the Rudding Museum.
I'm not sure if anybody who's at the Reading Museum was there twenty years ago.
I don't think anybody re uh remembers it.
Yeah, I wrote the review for that, and I actually had it out a while ago, and it's it was Doug Tyler who uh curated the show.
And uh St.
Mary's may be the wrong name of the college or whatever, but you're right.
I think you're right.
But that was uh it's tough remembering this stuff for twenty years or more anymore.
Tell me about it.
You know, uh we we were at you you always tell me every time we talked that you were your your first uh collection of holograms that you saw was at the uh uh at the Walnut Street Theater, which uh was when I uh I was circulating the Museum of Holography uh through the looking glass, which is an inaugural show.
We opened in in uh at the Walnut Street Theater.
Oh really?
And that was our first show.
Then we went to uh uh to Montreal and then we went down to Charlotte, North or to Raleigh, North Carolina, where that's where it started breaking attendance records.
You know, they had a a one-day attendance record breaking broken down there for that show.
And the show didn't go uh it was out for ten years, never came back to New York.
Isn't that something?
Uh I had one of the original posters from that show.
It was actually it wasn't called through the looking glass on the poster that they sold.
It was actually called the hologram show.
Oh really?
Yes.
Admission was uh fifty cents for children, I believe, and a dollar for adults.
Mid seventies.
Right.
Yeah.
But then uh then we took uh looking glass down to uh uh to Adelaide, Australia.
And then uh and then and then eventually uh it it went over to the Israel Museum in Jerusalem.
So it it got around for for a uh it was a nice show, and it's sort of the basis, the same model that the nature of philography is to show people who have never really seen a large collection of holograms.
Yeah.
You know what it looks like, what it's all about, and where it came from and and maybe a hint of where it's going.
Well I owe you a great deal of gratitude for uh for that show because that's what's actually spurred me on.
I mean, I saw my first hologram in sixty-eight and was something I always wanted to do, but right after I uh saw that show in Philadelphia, that's what cemented it.
And then once I bought the house, the holography handbook in nineteen eighty three got me started with my own studio, so there wasn't there there wasn't much uh written on the on uh holography back then.
No, no.
Any any book that you could get a hold of was was like gold.
I sat outside of that w uh uh Walnut Street Theater in a parking lot waiting for it to open in a nineteen sixty-two wildcat that we we didn't have any heat in the car, and it was in the middle of winter and we had to wrap ourselves in blankets 'cause I think we had an hour and a half before it opened.
A lot has changed since then.
That's for sure.
So uh it looks like you're doing a lot of new stuff there uh at your studio.
I try to keep ahead of the curve, you know.
Did you find out anything about the Florida show?
I haven't that's all right.
I have I tell you what, I I I'm I'm I'm running around with limited limited files.
I'll do it.
We'll uh we'll get that information out to the uh listeners.
One school in particular in Jacksonville was interested in it because they have holography as part of their program there.
Well, that's right.
Yeah.
You know, I notice you know, on my site I get uh you know, side meters here and see where people come from, and it's just amazing the number of uh of um uh universities and and colleges that that um send people to the history of holography, I guess just to sort of get them up to speed on where it where it came from.
That's on our website.
That history page that you had uh have is wonderful.
I actually link over to that too.
It's a wonderful history page.
And I and I keep adding stuff every once in a while.
Um unfortunately most recently since Leith and uh passed on and and of course uh our guru uh Steve Benton.
Yeah, yeah.
All right, anything else you want to add to to let people know about uh from the actual curator of the show?
Well, I think that's uh that's about it.
I I'll have to get back to you on the on those other dates.
Uh I know you have a long trip back, but you were so close to my house.
Is that right?
Where are you right now?
Well, I you know, I'm not sure.
I'm on uh route uh two twenty-two heading north.
Oh, okay.
I think I'm south of Allentown.
Yeah.
Well, you're more than welcome to come by if you'd like to.
I might try that on the way down.
I'm gonna come down and and um and uh break the show and then take it back to Connecticut.
All right, let's plan on that.
We'll have a lunch or dinner.
All right, that sounds good.
Can either go out for dinner or I can cook, either either way.
You can cook.
Yeah, I can cook.
Well, I'm amazed.
It comes from mixing all the chemicals.
Yeah.
You just uh substitute uh herbs and spices and you're a cook.
All right, Paul, I'll let you get back on the road.
All right, hey, thanks a lot.
Hopefully everything goes as plans for uh big opening weekend.
All right.
Well thanks again for your uh support and help there, Frank.
Well, thank you.
And look forward to seeing the show and look forward to seeing people during my presentation days.
Take care, Paul.
Thank you for calling.
Bye.